Right.
I'm pleased to welcome Leonard David
to our toxic Google program today.
Lennar David is an award winning space
journalist who has been reporting on
space activities for over 50 years.
He frequently contribute to the
website space.com as their space inside
columnist and as the coauthor of Buzz
Aldrin Mission to Mars in 2015 he became
the first recipient of the American
astronautical societies Ordway award for
sustained excellence and space flight
history and the category of journalism.
And in 2010 he received the
National Space Club press award.
Mars.
Our Future on the Red Planet considers
the eminent settlement of humans on Mars
backed by extensive research.
The book says the book is part of a
Major National Geographic Mars initiative
this fall, including the documentary
in partnership with Ron Howard.
Please join me in welcoming
Lennar David to Google today.
Right.
Well thanks so much for coming
in on your lunch break to,
there will be pictures of tomatoes
grown on Mars, so I help you who,
who doesn't have lunch will
be more hunger hungry. Uh,
I thought I'd start out with something.
I went to a book review from somebody
else and they were clever and reading in
their own words,
you know,
cause you write these and it's pretty
that first paragraph, you know,
when you get the assignment to do one of
these books, that first one is a killer.
And
in the 2030s,
a peculiar shadows slips across
the Reddish Vista. That is Mars.
The historic arrival of the first
expeditionary crew from Earth to the Red
Planet, balances on an impulsive
mix of rocket propulsion,
determine will and hard earned luck,
outstretch landing legs of
the craft near the planet.
A powered and safe descent by humans
onto Mars is a literal trial by fire.
So I got done with that and played piano
for a couple of hours and let me take
you on this trip.
I'm not going to be easy.
I think what I'm trying to get across,
it's going to be difficult and we liked
challenges and this is full of those
challenges.
Um,
I think one of the things that I'm proud
about this book is I tried to integrate
not just technical aspects.
I didn't want to shove a bunch of people
and habitats and give him a porthole
the lookout in a space suit and run
around out there and plant a flag salute,
grab rocks, come back home.
That's not what this is about.
And this is a kind of a really important
time frame and exploration of space.
Um, the book is sort of
divided into these chapters.
Yeah.
And this is a concept. I, I went
through a lot of editors and I,
I tried Mars land.
When I got done with this book,
I kept thinking people
kept sending me emails.
Every picture they've seen from Mars
that looks like someplace we been,
either it's Utah, southwest,
maybe Iceland's, some
people have been in Iceland.
Um,
it's a mixture of all that.
And I felt there was Myers land that
I wanted to project in this book.
And when I got the call
to write this book,
I was actually at a meeting at the
Lunar Planetary Institute and Houston,
Texas.
They brought in hundreds of scientists
to start looking at potential landing
zones for humans.
The first meeting of this type
and about 50 different sites.
On Mars became explorations zones.
I'll explain a little bit
more about what that is,
but these are the early preliminary,
uh,
sites that had been selected as potential
areas where a habitats can be first
put down on Mars.
Okay.
The key to this is exploration zones.
What does it mean?
It means that the humans can go to
different places within a certain,
uh,
say a hundred mile circle and find
all kinds of either resources,
scientific benefit to go there.
Um, and also problems, you know,
cause there's going to be really a lot
of mystery with Mars as much as we think
we know about it. My guess is we
got some Aha moments coming. Um,
you're sort of the artist's
concepts of first foot fall on Mars.
You know, what kind of crew makeup
will that be? How many will be there?
Six or seven. Somebody is a laggard
and they're waiting for him to,
or she didn't get out of there. I
be the commander. They can, sure.
They don't fall through the,
the dust or anything.
Okay.
Um,
one of the things about this particular
assignment for me doing the book was
it's part of a,
on a companion book to a six part series
that national geographic has just on
the edge of releasing.
The first one shows up on TV on National
Geographic Channel on November 14th.
Uh,
it's a docu drama and it has a crew and
you'll think be very much entertained
and,
uh,
excited and also a nervous
about what happens on this,
this particular expedition
and has some surprise endings.
Uh, but it, it reflects a lot of
what the book tries to get to,
which is a global vision.
How many countries are
really going to go to Mars?
You'd be surprised how many countries
have already gone to Mars through robotic
means. Right now, India has
an orbit around Mars. Uh,
Europe has a new webinar that
just started, uh, operations, uh,
that Nasa us have several.
Uh,
China is going to be launching a,
a rover to Mars in 2020.
Uh,
other countries have definitely picked up
the pace about the exploration of Mars.
So I did write a lot of our
global vision. Um, again,
the Indians, uh, Chinese
right now as we speak,
we've got to Chinese astronauts
up in their space lab. Um,
you know, to me in my, my little
world of space journalism, uh,
China's the story to watch.
They're very aggressive and it's going
to be very fascinating to watch them grow
in the next few years.
Lots of components of the Chinese space
program coming together pretty quickly.
European Space Agency is a key player.
Uh,
in the book I try to get to something
that's a bifurcation of exploration
objectives and goals.
One of them is the Europeans are very
interested in creating a moon village.
They're trying to bring together all
the countries that are a part of the
European Space Agency and perhaps put a,
uh,
a mini settlement on,
on the moon.
And there was a lot of this debate
discussion should be go to the moon,
back to the moon first.
Should we use the moon for fuel somehow
to make the Mars mission happen?
Um, I'm not going to go
into all the details of it,
but it's pretty well laid out in
the book. It has definitely, uh, uh,
a discussion point coming up about
where other countries may go in the next
decade or so.
Also,
this is a picture that just happened
a few days ago where the Europeans,
a crashed landed there,
a lander and nobody was on this.
This is a robotic craft,
but this is,
gets to the point that everybody
says that all the engineers,
and I know a lot of you are engineers,
Myers is hard and you know,
it's really hard when you slam
into it at 200 miles an hour.
But they lost this arbitrary. And just
even today, this morning, one of the,
one of the orbiters around
Mars has actually got some
new images in a definitely
a splattered
software failure apparently.
And a story I can't write yet,
but I think it's there.
I tar problems. You know,
people in the United States have
problems even talking about a Europe,
about software,
how many Ihr people are here?
Is there anybody who
really gets into the ITR?
I think this is what's going
to come out of this story. Um,
on a wildcard in all this is Elon Musk.
I mean, he's got this space, acts,
Tesla,
solar cities in Mexico a few,
several weeks ago now.
He unleashed his vision of where he
believes Mars exploration is going to go.
He's got an interplanetary
transport system he wants to build.
He definitely is. Um, I'm
getting old. I'm about 70.
To me,
he was like the Walt Disney,
a guy up there because when I was watching
tomorrow land on black and white TV
and the 50s,
while Disney,
you used to come out and parade out his
visions with Vern avant Braun and some
of these other people about space
travel on Mars was the objective.
And so I,
I felt like Alon touch my nerve
again because I remember Walt Disney.
Yeah.
This is one of his concepts.
Okay.
The thing to watch with Alon is the use
of the dragon capsule that is now in
use, uh, for uh,
hauling up cargo and eventually humans
to the international space station.
So a line's got a pretty gutsy plan
about trying to land these robotic,
uh,
craft this red dragon on Mars.
The key to this is you see
all that stuff coming down.
It's called supersonic retropropulsion.
And it's like the old days in
science fiction. I mean, we,
that's the way we used to do it. And Psi
Phi, you don't need the big parachute.
He can just land and,
um,
alon is already done. And as
a space x rocket, you know,
those drone ships he has out in the
water and then he's got land a land,
he lands on land.
Those are going to supersonic
retropropulsion maneuvers.
NASA is very interested in this technology
for getting larger and larger and
larger payloads on Mars.
So Alon is already a cutting
metal on a lot of good ideas.
Uh, the other thing in the book,
we got into his home base. Um,
I was surprised how many
analog sites around the planet,
people are going into little habitats.
This is in Hawaii
practicing Mars missions.
You see them all over the place.
There's, um, these are the,
the Mars want to be astronauts,
but,
but what they're learning things
that are thinking very practical.
One of them is this, the sociological
implications of five or six people,
uh, sharing food and wondering
who stole the m and m's. Uh,
uh, the one aspect that I did highlight
in the book is that we're going to start
pretty small. Uh, these
logistics flights to Mars.
You get a small lander, uh, with, uh, um,
these habitats kind of structured
this way, kind of small. Um,
but that's the beginning and this is,
this is all doable in my mind. And,
and we've already got robotic
craft on Mars that weigh a ton now,
but we got to learn how to get bigger
and bigger payloads down on the surface.
You know, here's another
expansion idea for habitats.
Okay.
Uh, one big, uh,
discussions coming up is should we
stay in Mars' orbit and you as teller
robotics to actually glue the habitats
together before astronauts humans get
there.
Um,
it's an interesting development
and telepresence and tell
a robotics and that's
moving along in a separate wavelength.
And we'll see.
I think it's going to be a
major player no matter what.
But there is a lot of discussion about
having an orbiter with people in it
around Mars actually assemble,
uh,
the site that eventually humans
will go to before they get there.
So the raw robots will be
sort of be waving to the
astronauts as they climb off.
So we'll have a pretty good review ahead
of time through robotic eyes are what
the habitat looks like, uh, before
even humans set foot on Mars.
Here's tomato pictures.
So those are you still hungry?
This is a big issue.
You know,
we are beyond Tang.
It's the 21st century.
So uh, things are happening in some, uh,
biology labs and how a bad
crop growth. Uh, how much, uh,
came over your lie on crops grown on Mars.
How do we grow, what happens to them?
Um, what nutrients are needed. Again,
this is short about a conceptual module
with the whole greenhouse jammed in
there. I got a feeling people are going
to be on Mars, are going to be very thin.
I wish I was there some days.
But anyway,
one of the best thing
is it's going on now.
Some very creative three d
printing construction concepts
and this is where it's
going to go this way.
We're not going to have tin cans
with people hunker down in there.
I think we're going to start using the
local resources of Mars to actually use
construction,
uh,
materials and actually build new
kind of structures on Mars. Uh,
that makes it nicer. There's living
rooms, there's, you know, all kinds of,
there's a TV room over
to the right side maybe,
but also Mars has got a lot of water
and a lot of ice under the surface.
And one other, the new architectural
concepts is this ice, um,
ice house on bars.
So who's to say,
all I know is people are
really looking at right now
that's from inside the ice house.
Okay.
Also caves on Mars.
We're looking for caves.
Should we go back to cave living?
That wasn't it.
I didn't get down to that, but that's,
that's a circle there for a writer.
It's kind of fun to think about it.
We came out of the cave and we're going
back into the caves and Mars. But the, uh,
the idea here is that you're much more
protected in these caves from ultra
violets and, uh, and uh,
my guess is mission control would have
a hard time letting people go and caves.
But we'll see. Um, they're
definitely there on Mars.
So how are we going to use them? Uh, a
big issue is mobility on Mars. I mean,
once you've got your
explorations zone started,
what kind of equipment are really going
to have to use to move around and get to
places on Mars? And how much time
are they going to have outside? Uh,
how far should they go away from
the habitat in case the, the, uh,
rover kind of breaks down and the people
got to trudge back to the habitat for
safety.
Uh,
these are all early things that the Apollo
program ran into as well because they
didn't let the astronauts drive off
into the sunset and then have a,
a wheel fall off and tried to
get back to the lunar module.
So there's some operational problems
here about mobility on Mars.
One way around that is having, uh,
the astronauts have the ability
to actually launch balloons.
Okay.
Make use of little robot hoppers.
There's this design of a Mars airplane,
kind of a remote pilot vehicle from
ours and all controlled by the people on
Mars so they can extend
that zone a of exploration.
So I,
that's the other shoe that's going to
dropping now is how are we going to get
the blending of humans and the robotic
tools they need to really do an
investigative,
uh,
multi expeditionary look at
Mars tumbleweed using the
winds of Mars instrumented
tumbleweeds science payloads.
Some of these could be
unleashed across the polar caps.
Okay.
But then,
okay,
we get past the kind of
cool technical thing.
You start talking to someone,
a psychologist and some of the people
who have done reports on submarines and
Antarctic and in any of the polar bases
and you start seeing some trouble signs
here. Um, here's a trouble sign.
These guys went on strike in Skylab.
Uh, there was a moment there.
They had so much coming in from mission
control. They said, we're outta here.
We're cutting off calm. We're
going to enjoy this. You
got that. You got too much,
uh, operational paperwork.
We got to go through.
And they s there was an actual strike by
astronauts on board the sky lab so they
had some time to fool around.
Okay.
Uh,
the thing that's happening now is the,
certainly the international space station
and the key thing, it's international,
you know,
multiple,
multiple countries have participated
in this huge engineering feat. Um,
early on we all thought, well, you know,
is this the white elephant and space I
was, I'm probably guilty like everybody,
why, how much money is this
thing going to cost? Uh,
it's turning out to be what promise to be,
which is a test bed for a lot of hardware,
a lot of ideas and also understand
the physiological, sociological,
cultural impacts that
happen in micro gravity.
And it is becoming a testbed
for moving on to Mars.
We're getting a lot of interesting,
provocative signals out of
the space station program.
Just a kind of a beauty shot
of the earth and the person.
Okay.
They have, I keep talking to
the astronauts. This is the,
this is a calm moment because a lot of
I'm trying to cram in there and it's hard
to see out the window when he
got six or seven heads in there
haircuts in space.
That's a big issue.
Yeah.
Again, what are we learning
about, you know, life far away,
even though it's only 300 miles up.
Yeah.
Music is a big thing.
That's another big issue of trying to be
responsive to your own timeframe
and you can have fun. Uh,
I've seen some pretty interesting sports
that have shown up with m and m's again
and,
and they,
they take duct tape and make balls out
of him and try to lob it between the
modules and see who hits a target.
So I think just again,
it's going to be an early
signature of what Mars exploration.
We'll be alive with people having to have
downtime and not be so under pressure.
Okay.
A very interesting experiment. Just a, um,
a while back with mark and Scott
Kelly. There were twins. Um,
here's,
he,
he stayed up on the space station for
a year and his brother went through all
these medical tasks and as a control,
a person for a,
for a whole new look at what happens
to genetics and space. And, uh,
uh, he came up with all kinds of
interesting comments about his,
his trip. And, uh, I, I, NASA
hasn't even put it all together yet,
but there's definitely a, some, again,
a lot of really positive things
and some things we got to watch.
But that was a year long
mission, uh, by Scott Kelly and,
uh,
came back on a saw,
use a capsule and landed in Russia.
And,
uh, obviously the biggest
question mark and, uh,
in exploration of Mars is,
you know,
whereas the life is that
there and if it's there,
should we be worried about us
contaminating it or it contaminate us?
We don't know. And, uh, we see things,
evidence of surface water.
These are probably the worst
kind of name you could ever give.
Something that's kind of exciting. These
are called recurring slope linear. Yay.
This is, I go to conferences
and I the recurring slope, NEA,
that paper we found new ones.
Okay. Um, there's something
happening, seeping of water.
There was some speculation that some of
these things are fed by huge aquifers
underneath the surface. My guess
is that's probably true. Um,
and where there's water is their life.
So Mars still is hauntingly
okay.
Touching her nerves about
finding life on Mars.
And is it a second genesis of life?
Is it,
is it life that somehow came from
earth and landed on Mars or vice versa?
One of the things that people talk
about and I wrote about in the book is,
is it possible that Mars,
uh,
had microbial life really early in the
formation of the planets and it was
impacted in microbial life
on Mars came to Earth.
So we are the marshes and the irony is
that we're going to go back the home
planet.
Okay.
Um,
the life question is one that is a,
also an ethical ones and I've spent
a lot of time and energy on that.
And one of the chapters
about terraforming Mars,
can we make an earth to,
you know,
are there ways that we can transform
Mars and make it more suitable to you?
Human kind. Uh, Tara farming,
we do it all the time here in the book.
We talk about global climate change.
That's terraforming. We just don't
have the levers right to control it.
And we are trying to make certain rules
and regulations to control climate
change. But can you bring that
to that planet and alter it,
particularly when our life force
has been on that planet and as,
as hunkered down there and then what
happens, uh, to the life on that planet.
So we,
what is the ethical boundaries
of exploration and using
Mars to kind of do the
Mars makeover.
Okay.
The best thing is going on
for people in the morning.
You get up for a rye imagery coming from
Mars is actual pictures from curiosity.
Landed on Mars in August of 2012.
Uh,
it's a one ton nuclear powered rover,
still cranking.
Does great work.
Very slow from August,
2012 to just a few days ago.
It has driven I nine miles,
nine miles.
Okay.
You get some geologists down there and
they're going to kick that thing out of
the way and keep going, you know, so, um,
it's a slow process, but you got to
multibillion dollar kind of investment.
You gotta be careful about how you run it.
And it's,
it's really a very fascinating
piece of hardware. A,
these are the kinds of real,
this is real imagery from curiosity rover.
This is the kind of things that sees.
And every morning I get up and look at
the next set of raw imagery and it's
pretty,
it really is cool.
How many people think you've been there?
I mean, is it, is, does it look familiar?
Am I wrong? I had been somewhere
like that and I've seen that,
okay,
this is a danger.
This is one of those I could
see me walking by and that
thing falling in on me.
Um, so that's, and that is
one of the points of the book.
There's some danger here. This is not
going to be a slam dunk kind of mission.
And, um, so we've gotta be very
careful how we pulled this off
the giant leap. Um, one
of the things, again,
I'm trying to pull together,
when you go back and look at
exploration on the earth, we've really,
you can go anywhere. You can go into the
top of mountains, you can go under sea,
you can go to deserts, you
can go to Arctic regions. Um,
you can do all that.
And one of the things that always happen
as a humans create the technology that
the suits, the whatever, you know, to
conquer whatever environment they're in.
And it's the same way with Mars. We got
new kinds of suits people are looking at.
Uh,
the key with this issue is
a mobility on the planet.
These people can't just, you know,
kind of, um, just walk around,
they're going to have to do a lot of
work and if something breaks down,
they're going to have to repair.
So there all kinds of new mobility
devices on suits to give them more
flexibility.
Um,
this is the biggest element.
Okay.
I don't know where all
this is going to go.
I all I know is that
people are working very,
very hard about getting people to Mars.
And it's not just the U S
it's multiple countries. Uh,
the political will and leadership of
any nation that undertakes this kind of
event. Uh, even if it's a global event,
there has to be some kind of leadership
role to sort of coordinate everything.
A bomb has been interesting. He's made
some talks just about going to Mars.
We're going, uh, then we
have an administration change
and I, I'm getting old,
but I lived in Washington DC for 30 years
and every time one of these people get
in, they look at NASA and I shift
things around and try to, it's just,
it's another issue they got to
deal with the last go around.
They totally trashed the, uh, one, uh,
really a synergistic and exploration
driven space program and put in the,
the shuttle got shutdown and,
and money got moved to this or that.
So it's hard to keep this momentum going.
Uh,
so this is going to be very, this is a key
thing. Where's that going to come from?
What countries you actually
going to take that role? Uh,
I call it,
uh,
I'm trying this on you because
I can't figure out what it is.
But at the end of the book,
when I got done, I got,
I pushed the send button on the last
chapter and I kept thinking, you know,
back in the old exploration days and
exploration of the oceans in particular,
it's, it's a ship going
off the edge of the earth.
They were worried the sea
serpents whirlpools scurvy.
I mean,
they went through all these things and
I think we're sort of doing the same
thing to ourselves.
Cosmic Rays,
Michael gravity radiation.
Okay.
There's less gravity on Mars. What
does it do to you? Psychology?
I think micro gravity, maybe the
scurvy up today for space travelers.
It's the kind of thing we'll defeat
somehow. There'll be some new ideas.
They'll be new ways to do that. And for
the first time, everybody in this room,
uh, w you know, the people going to
Mars are going to be interactive.
I mean, this is going to be, we're
all going to go. Uh, I don't, I,
I'm sure there'll be something
else other than Gopro, but did it,
will be on their helmets and will
virtually be there with them for the first
time in exploration history.
Will,
we're all going to be able to partake
in this kind of unique travel to another
world.
And I call it now history.
It's something totally now never
been done before. And in fact,
I hate to bother you guys up,
but I couldn't have written this book
without Google. It just, you know,
for a research person and trying to
understand all the different parameters of
exploration of Mars, uh, the Internet, uh,
how powerful it is and you can
see where it's going to go.
You guys are leading the charge
on Google earth, Google, Mars. Um,
it's definitely going to be interactive
exploration like nothing we've ever had
before.
So,
Mars,
we need you and I hope you'll contribute
to the figuring out how best to solve
some of these tough problems
I've kind of outlined here. Um,
there's the book, I hope you get the
book, I think. How many seconds do I go?
I gotta go, I gotta do this.
I got something declassified.
How many here have a security
clearance? Okay, well nevermind. Uh,
this is Leonard David in
the kind of late in the 60s.
I went to Mars with my
project epic experimental,
prolonged isolation jammer. I and my
mom called it the die a death trap.
So here I am in my Mars Habitat.
I built this out of plywood and some
of the most advanced technologies I had
available to me at the home depot.
We had reversed vacuum
cleaners to exchange the air.
We had a life support equipment,
uh,
you know, toilets. We had
it all in there. And uh,
there's some elaborate
a circuitry that was a,
I borrow from the ninth grade
and then electronic class 10 can,
I don't even know what that
was. Uh, this was, you know,
recycling.
Here's my friend.
Jerry was about as crazy as I was
and so I stayed in it for 12 hours.
Jerry stayed in there for 24.
He would, he broke the record.
This is me inside this thing.
I had my little control panel
cleverly. You have a note thing. So
I can take notes. It's cold in here.
Most of us were sent to NASA by the way,
and I take that picked up in
a couple of points. Again,
some of the advanced circuitry
that you learned or you
can take notes and dark.
We had an air lock so we can pass food.
It would have had that tech a lot of time.
Didn't make sure that this is light,
no light getting in. No
light. That was hard. Anyway,
that was my trip back in the late sixties.
I appreciate your time
here and uh, I hope, uh,
we have little time for
questions and again,
thank you for sharing
your lunch hour with me.
Anything, Eh, I guess you're supposed to
use a microphone if that's the procedure.
Um, so you talked about the telepresence
mission with humans in Mars' orbit,
controlling robots below to,
uh, assemble the habitats. Um,
as you probably know,
the uh,
mission design that I find very intriguing
anyway is send humans to Mars but
never land them.
You send humans to Mars,
but they stay in orbit or maybe on
Phobos or Damos our tele or our tele.
Tell operating robots on the planet
below so you get rid of the light time
delays that you have with current
robotic exploration. Right. Um,
but you never have to fight more as
gravity. Well, Dave, opinions about that
mission design, you know, I, it's,
I'm just excited we can debate
it, you know. Oh, should
we go down to the surface?
There's no our bet. Okay, that's
great. Let's just get there now.
We'll figure it out.
But I do think the tele robotics is
going to play a role no matter what.
If you've got humans on Mars,
they're going to be doing a
lot of tele robotic things.
The idea about the teller robotics,
the first guy that I,
Fred singer actually had a,
what he called the Phd Program,
which is Phobos and Deimos program.
He made that point. He said,
this life on Mars,
is that an issue?
And maybe we should just have sterilized
robots running around down there. Um,
I don't know which way
it's going to go in.
My guess is it's going to be shoot the
Indians and ask questions later. You know,
I'm afraid of that.
Uh,
Robert Zubrin or the Mars society is
very big on, don't worry about it.
And I think there's enough people in
planetary protection and is saying,
let's worry about it now. And we, in fact,
we probably have already fouled up
and asked a little bit here and there.
So it's a good point.
I don't know which way it's going to go,
but I hope that discussion happens and
that we were just arguing between, oh,
well, you know, let's stay in orbit
or go down. Let's get to that point.
My question is,
uh,
what do you see as Google's
role or potential role in
the colonization of Mars?
Well, I, that's why I said
I, I do think you have, uh,
a seminal role here. And really, I
mean it's, I think the whole team,
I know you guys are what,
20,
I don't know how many offices
are all over the place, but yeah,
how do we increase the public
participation, citizen science? I mean,
people want to be involved and
I think the more we can do,
everybody can take ownership in this.
Everybody can be a
pioneer at the same time.
Never been done before on that
scale of exploration and I,
so whatever,
you know,
feedback loops or whatever
it's going to be in the future.
I just see this as an opportunity for
everybody and the more people realize that
they are actually going to learn by being
involved in this and letting people do
whatever they're going to do on the
surface. And you know, again, I,
it'd be beyond Gopro cameras,
but there's a cool thing coming up on
the Mars 2020 rover from Nasa for the
first time. They have hearing devices
on there. We'll actually hear Mars.
So synthesizing the feel of
Mars and hearing what's on Mars.
I'm not sure if we're going to hear
barking dogs. Maybe you never know. Uh,
but the of wins of Mars and that being
another human capability on that planet I
think is that to me is exciting.
I was wondering if you could comment a
little bit on some of the timelines and I
dunno if you want to say anything about
the plan I read about recently for
100,000 colonists.
Yeah, that's Alon. Alon Musk is a
driven, driven the dream machine.
You know,
he's,
he's got a pretty interesting concept and,
you know,
he's the guy that's put his
money where his mouth is. I mean,
he's building rockets, he's
exploding rockets. He's learning. Uh,
we've got a ways to go for, I see
you didn't have planetary transports,
but I mean he's got the master plan Kinda
from ours in his mind of how it could,
could work. Um, you know,
I think what I liked about his
talk and Mexico was that he,
he, he made it sound like this is
happening. This is where we're, I'm going,
come along, you know. And so I
think that's all helpful. Uh,
every engineer I talked to after
his talk you to have more detail,
we're going to have a lot
more detail on that one.
So I think alliance got his work cut
out for him to actually explain some of
the, a, in fact there's some, uh,
some early essays that are being written
now about and criticizing some of its
parts of his mission. But
anyway, it's fine. To me, it's,
that's part of the deal.
That lawn,
he's got to make rockets go up and
come down. He's got that down. He's,
you have this explosion with
a space x rocket the other,
a couple months ago or
whatever it was. So, you know,
he's not out of the woods about success.
So we'll see. I think it's great.
That's about all I can say about it.
Let's make it happen. Anything else there?
Um, I want to ask, um,
I know it was that Mohs or it's kind of
like [inaudible] and other people are
thinking about colonize
a moon and a Venice.
Others fear 50 miles can
system the human balloon.
Compare all of this, uh, a cons
plying which fine, you've seen cases
or at least take or cost benefit.
Yeah. Here's the problem.
This is why I'm old and crotchety now
because I signed up for looking at space
and reporting about space long time ago,
and the visionaries at the time,
you know, we're blowing up rockets,
but next to you on overhead
dogs barking in space, uh,
and the timelines that were
suggested, go to the moon, go to Mars.
We're going to Alpha Centauri
interstellar flight. And I go, okay,
that sounds good. Sounds like a
checklist thing. Let's do all those.
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm advocating having a strong space
program that has all those elements in it.
I this idea that somehow we get to Mars
and it's all over is not part of my
dream.
Um,
I've written about interstellar travel
and there's lots of things you can see
coming in the physics journals.
We're going to be,
the solar system's going to shrink where
there's the speed levels were going at
an hour.
Not going to be the way we're doing this.
I flew out here from New
York last night and I, I,
if I was in a Conestoga wagon,
I'd still becoming,
let's say I'm not going to make it. Um,
so transportation is going to change.
We're going to get around the solar
system much faster. So going to the moon,
going to El Point's going to Mars.
I,
that should be some
kind of integrated plan.
If one country wants to pull
the lunar village together,
NASA is very keen on not
spending money on the moon again,
but going to a Mars, even buzz when
I worked on the book with Buzz,
I mean he doesn't want us tax
dollars going back to the moon.
He wants to spend the money on
Mars. But we'll see. I, like I said,
there's this European view of setting up
a lunar village that you could take the
resources there on the moon and make fuel,
send them up to a position in space and
that's the fuel you might want to use
for your Mars transport
system. So, you know,
whatever happens.
It's cool as long as we don't discontinue
everything because other countries are
moving out. I think it's clear to
me if he, if he have leadership,
you had political, do you have
a technological drive? Uh,
in a country? I think the space program,
uh, makes that happen. They can,
it can do those kinds of things.
It'd be a lot of spin offs
and those kinds of things.
I'm not a big spinoff person.
I glad it happens,
but I'm into into it for the
exploration of it. I just think that's,
this is what humans do.
And Meyers is a metaphor for exploration.
It's a metaphor for scientific discovery
and also danger that that was a great
elements for a drama.
Anything else?
Second question.
So what is it about Mars that excites
more interest in exploration than say,
Venus? Yeah, I like Venus
too. It's hot. So hot.
Uh, there's a lot of talk about life's
in the clouds of Venus. I Dunno,
there's some new books come in and
will be very interesting. Uh, again,
I don't really, I try not to, you know,
in my lifetime I lost a planet.
Pluto got demoted. I mean, I, as a kid,
I had to learn all those plants and then
you get one tossed off and I then I,
then all of a sudden we have
exoplanets discovered everywhere.
I've gained several thousand or a
thousand, whatever the number is today.
Maybe they'd discovered something
last night. Um, I'm sorry,
what was the question?
Venus and Mars,
I don't know Venus going to be there.
There are some new spacecraft
they're going to go to.
Venus will understand it more
the greenhouse effect on Venus.
Is it something, a precursor to the
way the earth is going to go under you?
You hear all that, you know the classic
line hint. It's so hot. It melts lad.
Okay, well prove it. I
don't know. Um, I, uh,
I, I think Venus is, is
interesting in its own right.
They're all interesting. I mean, there's
a lot of people want to go to Europa.
We have a mission that's
being prescriptive for your
rope and landing on an icy
moon.
And that these moons are turning out to
be interesting because of the potential
for oceans underneath the
ice. What's, you know,
you've got people look trying to put
a little detectors for whale sounds or
something. I don't know what they're
going to be looking for. Anyway.
I think all those are a player because
we're starting to learn about our own
backyard and this transportation thing
of moving around much faster and,
uh, is going to happen. So I think
everything's going to be accessible.
We can do a lot more.
And the biggest thing is coming in here,
a planetary exploration is a cube sats.
You're going to start seeing these
things as a small sats. I mean,
I go do articles about people that worked.
I've worked on the Galileo program.
It took me 15 years of my
life, you know, and, and uh,
now you can put these things
in a lab and a couple months,
test them out. You get them on a
rocket. They're going to be some cubes.
Ads launched a lob to the
moon here in a few years.
So interplanetary and small sats
are kind of coming together.
So things like Venus and
launching little balloons,
they can travel around Venus.
I'm up for it all.
They're all, all, all planners are good.
Okay.
Anything else? Okay. I
really appreciate your time.
It's been
okay.
Oh, can you? Okay. Yep.
I'd be remiss because the book is to
companion piece to the trailer on a starch
to November 14th at.
This gives you an idea of where
they're going in a docker drama. Yeah.
Place where you feel safest place,
where you belong.
Six months ago we left that place.
We shut the confirm our warms
the planet across the void,
even though we might not do it, is
our mission to make this place home.
Mars a global event series coming this
fall to the national geographic channel.
I didn't give you much. There
is a surprise ending. Let me,
let me finish with one thing that I,
I long time ago I met Ray,
anybody or Ray Bradbury Fan,
ray Bradbury,
I just,
I was putting a conference together at
jet propulsion lab and Ray Bradbury was
the speaker and I got a chance
to talk to him and I said,
I really admire your writing and
you know, how, how do you do it all?
And he's like, he looked for the
metaphor, look for the letter for
it.
Took me a while to figure that out.
But I am I a the I but I ended
the book with Ray Bradbury. Uh,
he in 1976,
Bradbury rejoiced in the touchdowns of
the Viking one and two robot robotic
landers on Mars sang today
we have touched Mars,
there is life on Mars and it is us
extensions of our eyes in all directions.
Extensions of our mind,
extensions of our heart and soul.
I've touched Mars today.
That's the message she'll look for there.
We are on Mars.
We are the Martians,
so thanks again.
Appreciate it.
[inaudible].